Democrats say there should be no further
strikes against Iran without
congressional approval this sets the
stage for another showdown with Congress
chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett is at the White House major
house this likely to play out well the
White House asserts that the president
had the legal authority to take this
action not only as commander in chief
but under the Iraq war resolution of
2002 and quite clearly president Trump
is betting that the killing of sulamani
and those within his strategic inner
circle will deter further Iranian
aggression but if it doesn't the
president used his Twitter feed
yesterday to alert Congress that the US
will retaliate and we quote here perhaps
in a disproportionate manner that
prompted House Speaker Nancy Pelosi to
send a letter to all of her Democratic
colleagues announcing that the house
will introduce and vote on a War Powers
Resolution this week she said to limit
the president's military actions
regarding Iran and top Senate Democrats
are demanding the White House declassify
its notification of Congress for the
justification for the sulemani attack
arguing the reasons for this high-risk
decision must be presented to the public
now however Democrats and Republicans
debate the legal authorities the
underlying intelligence or the way
Congress has been brought in or excluded
from this debate all of these issues
will also deal with the question of
presidential power and those questions
of presidential power will not or can't
be separated from the question that
still looms a Senate impeachment trial
for president Trump Tony another front
for the debate major thank you very much
you